in today's world many people can't
imagine their lives without coffee
starting the day with a cup of the black
caffeine-filled brew is a given part of
the daily routine
it helps us stay alert at work or when
we're up late at night studying or
working on some project but what most
people don't know
is that this everyday beverage has very
strong
mystical and religious origins being
strongly connected
to sufism and the islamic mystics
[Applause]
coffee may not seem all that special to
some
i'm not much of a coffee drinker myself
i prefer tea but
the history of coffee is definitely very
interesting whether you like to drink it
or not
coffee is made from the coffee bean
which is actually the seeds of
berries that grow on the famous coffee
plants
these beans originate in ethiopia and
have been known and probably consumed by
the local population for a long time
even though there is no actual direct
evidence for this
so technically the history of coffee
begins here but at this early time the
coffee bean was actually chewed on
the coffee bean as we all know is very
strong in
caffeine which is a compound that
increases
alertness and makes us feel just more
up or more awake more sort of
clear-headed you could say
technically caffeine is actually
classified as a psychoactive drug and
its
effect can be quite strong and just
chewing on the beans themselves as the
ethiopians probably did obviously has
this same effect
but coffee doesn't become a beverage
until
much later it isn't until the coffee
bean reaches the arabian peninsula
yemen on the southern tip of the arabian
peninsula that it's touched to be
brewed into an actual drink into a
beverage
we're not entirely sure when coffee
reached yemen but
the earliest evidence is from the 1400s
so we know that it existed at that
point and perhaps earlier than that as
well and this
is when coffee's relationship with islam
and
sufism really starts one popular theory
is that coffee was actually introduced
to yemen by a sheikh umar
ashad ali who belonged to the shadoli
sufi
order but irregardless of the actual
story what is certain
is that the sufis in yemen very quickly
realized that this new
beverage was very useful for their
mystical practices
the sufis who are often referred to as
islamic mystics are known for their
characteristic rituals and
practices they did and still do often
gather together in sessions called
hadra where they will take part in
various forms of very intense
devotion to god from praying to
meditating listening to and playing
music and the most characteristic ritual
which is known as
vikr or remembrance in
vicar the names of god or certain
phrases are repeated for very
long periods of time and the
practitioners will often enter a kind of
trans or ecstatic state at least ideally
that's what you want to achieve
these mystical sessions often go on for
very long periods of time
and also often take place at night as
this can be very
challenging and tiring of course the
sufis of yemen realized that the very
strong
caffeine effect of coffee was very
useful to stay awake and alert
during their long vicar sessions at
night now as a result of this
the coffee completely exploded in the
region
it became a kind of sufi drink that was
used in mystical practice
and quickly then spread across the
entire arabian peninsula
but at this time it was almost
exclusively used to improve spiritual
and mystical practices
that was only later with the arrival of
the ottoman empire that coffee
eventually spread to
other regions in the middle east and
eventually beyond
by the year 1600 or so coffee was
widespread
across multiple continents it was
at that point had reached europe and
india and many other places
even as it spread it was still used
primarily at first by
sufis in their mystical practices used
in a very practical sense but
as it spread wider and the time went on
a lot of people also started to
actually enjoy the drink itself it
caught the attention of people who just
liked to drink it without any other kind
of practical
usages for it and so coffee houses were
opened across the ottoman empire where
people could gather
drink coffee and discuss things with
their friends
things like politics or religion or any
subject really we eventually saw similar
developments in
europe and in both of these regions
there started a
huge debate on the permissibility of
drinking this black beverage
in the islamicate world in the ottoman
empire for the most part
jurists and sultans debated whether
coffee was permissible under islamic law
this was partly due to more directly
religious questions
that coffee obviously had a psychoactive
effect on people and so obviously
questions arose
as to its similarity to other
intoxicants like
wine and whether or not it should be
prohibited on on that very basis
but another important factor in this
debate was of course
political some would say this was
actually the main factor behind this
whole
debate as i said coffee houses had
become a place where people could
very freely discuss things like
politics and so this to a degree also
undermined
the power and influence of the sultans
and
the leaders and these kinds of people of
power and so
the coffee houses thus became a direct
threat
to the power and influence of the
leaders
the occasional prohibition of coffee
drinking which did appear at this time
is therefore mostly a direct result of
this
coffee was a direct threat to the
establishment
and almost identical debates and
situations also appeared in europe
at around the same time but today for
the most part we've all reached the
conclusion that coffee is a-okay
and with a very small number of
exceptions it is legal in most parts of
the world
now t actually has a somewhat similar
story
all chu ti as it is called comes from
the same plant the camellia sinensis
which has its origins in china this
includes all the famous teas the green
tea black tea
white tea yellow tea oolong and so on
and as with coffee
the tea leaf was originally chewed in
china
but later also started to be brewed with
water at least as early
as the han dynasty this is between 200
bc
to 200 ce it is said that t
was originally pretty centralized or
confined to the region of yunnan but
the arrival of buddhism in the region
may have been an important
factor in its wider spread across china
with the arrival of buddhism in china
through different buddhist
monks tea quickly became an important
part
of religious practice for these
buddhists
much like the sufis the buddhists monks
would often sit in long periods in
meditation which was very tiring very
very energy consuming and so
tea which also contains caffeine albeit
not
as much as coffee was a useful way to
stay alert and awake
during meditation also a way to recover
after a long meditation session
and so much like with the sufis in
southern arabia
tea became an integral part of buddhist
practice
in china at this time so the buddhist
monks as they spread across
all of china and later into japan and
korea
brought with them tea and thus helped
facilitate its larger spread
later of course tea became an integral
part of buddhism in china and japan
not just for its helpful effects but
also in a kind of symbolic and
ceremonial way
text written about the symbolic
significance of tea relating it to
buddhist and taoist philosophies
were written in the later periods the
tang dynasty the ming dynasty and so on
for example we all know about the famous
tea ceremony in chinese and japanese
culture
the tea ceremony was developed in a
context of zen
buddhism where the ceremonial
preparation
sharing and drinking of tea became a
spiritual practice in itself
like a kind of meditation if you will
these practices
still continue to this day there is of
course a lot more we could discuss when
it comes to the
religious or mystical dimensions of
coffee and tea
we in the west we often like to believe
that religion has its own little pocket
in society that's separated from
everything else
or indeed that we as a secularized
modern society is
free from influence by religion but
often when we start to dig deeper into
very
mundane things like coffee for example
which is something we drink basically
every day
we start to realize that very basic
things are
strongly connected to religious
traditions
huge important and and significant
parts of our lives that we don't realize
are strongly connected to
religious traditions and we often don't
realize this
the history and origins of coffee is
strongly
intimately connected with islamic
mysticism or sufism
tea in a similar way would not have
spread to our parts of the world
if it wasn't for the buddhist monks and
their mystical practices as well
so the next time you sit there in the
morning with your regular cup of coffee
maybe remember that the whole reason
you're having that experience
is thanks to muslim mystics and their
devotional religious practices
i'll see you next time
you